mais bon le gisèle souci du détail alors
là quand ils boivent chat dg on boit dj
nbi au sort toujours pas de temps en
temps qu on ne boit on voit surtout du
28e ça se passe autour elle voit en bois
des petits vins haut de gamme et aux
champignons bois très peu de vin dans
l'autre néanmoins j'ai relevé complet du
marché manchette on en boit beaucoup du
petit sarc un petit service à bois
beaucoup c'est du whisky et laure vous
chez vous en bois dans nestor burma une
boîte du sac à dos 2-2 dans le temps
mais plus savons pourquoi sur quoi bull
et il devient contrat avec l'amap
jetteront public il ya des millions de
gens par les maîtres chanteurs et vous
de vous avez des contrats dont j'ai pas
de contrôle
il ya un contrat avec un marchand un
trafiquant d'armes non il ya une
quinzaine d'années dans jeu dans le jeu
des buts et j'ai créé toute une série de
romans policiers
d'espionnage qui n'ont jamais paru est
actuellement exécrables
il y avait des tas de contrats
mirifiques à la clé paraît-il mais
l'éditeur malgré ces contrats a fait
faillite
les choses ont été jetés chaleur à
propos des mardis de l'art de cigarettes
ce truc il ya quand même une chose dans
le roman il y à des marques qui sont
dans le domaine public 1 qui peuvent
avoir un pernaut il faut le dire qu'il
doit internautes et non pas simplement
un apéritif ça fait partie de la vie
ordinaire
seulement alors évidemment il ya des
auteurs toutes les pages moi j'avais
même une scène où le type était au bar
et le barman lui et lui mérite tout ce
qu'il y avait avant
mais le souci du détail ce n'est pas une
caractéristique du roman policier par
rapport au roman
par exemple manchettes il est son
personnage je crois c'est bouché
manchette écoute beaucoup de jazz
alors vous nous donnez la marque de
landéan simple la marque de radio k7 les
noms des mécaniciens s'est de suite
parce que c'est un c'est un cadre c'est
un essai d'un homme guette entièrement
entouré d'objets précis de marquillies
des revues proment sur la haute fidélité
où tout le monde analyse profondément la
différence entre tel et l ampli je n'y
connais rien c'est un homme qui a un
certain passé précis donc qui skie à
aimer le jazz à un certain moment précis
de sa jeunesse au moment où c'était tel
stick de jazz et pas telle autre
est ce à dire est ce ça mais ça lui
donne un âge d'aveux d'aidé précisément
ces musiques là et puis tous les objets
qui l'entourent c'est précisément ça qui
l'étouffé qui va définir pour les faire
cavaler mais parlera vous donner des
tapes il trempait une tri scott dans du
thé spécial fabrique phase de forte
n'amène mazen c'est sa femme et
nous avons immédiatement c'est une
emmerdeuse ah bon avoir rattrapé à
l'autre